did you see that video luke rudkowski
reposted today where it's like someone
protesting outside of trump towers and
they're like we want him arrested for
the provable crimes they're like oh what
provable crimes and he's like
provable crime uh
i i gotta stop the interview right now
actually and it's the most awkward this
is freaking hilarious let me see i'm
just trying to find going down down down
there it is right here
wait wait i always got to fix the audio
oh is the audio oh he's got to make sure
the audio is going to the people who are
actually watching the show i don't know
what the comment is this unprecedented
to arrest a former president for not
turning into a former president that had
committed this many provable criminal
acts but what are the provable criminal
acts i guess
approval criminal acts well
i'm just i i
i'm done talking is this unpleasant i'm
done
can i just say on on the left i've had
people do that wave at me like i'm done
we're done we're done it's like where
did that come from when did that become
a thing you could just say there's
these mind viruses around you'll hear
people talking right and they'll say
right after they say something as if
they're asking you if what they're
saying is correct wow it's like a cult
it's like a tribal cult
recognition thing like up speak right i
hear rogan talking about it yeah yeah
and sometimes if you ask someone
something and then you make the
statement right like you're really
asking am i right that's a different
thing when you when you're just doing it
to get people to agree with you it's
this weird insecurity thing it started
in like the last two years watch for it
it's not i want to i want to play the
game with with this guy on this
interview i don't know i want to play
too so uh trump's provable crimes um
i don't think there are any i can
criticize him for during because during
his administration the state department
was advertising his golf resorts or his
resorts and he did try to have uh i
believe the g7 at trump darrell those
were like things i was like hey whoa man
you know and then he backed when he was
like well i think i should do it but uh
crimes
spare me the quid pro quo with ukraine
let's play a game should joe biden be
arrested for his provable crimes okay
well um
i want to be sincere and get the nuance
in the context correct so i should say
there should be an investigation into
joe biden based on probable cause
available to the public notably that i
believe it was the council on foreign
relations uh meeting he was speaking
publicly and stated that uh he engaged
in a quid pro quo with ukraine with
ukraine
something that we were told was illegal
so uh considering he admitted that he
said to the president of ukraine if you
don't if you don't uh fire the
prosecutor you're not getting a billion
dollars okay right there impeached and
or charged criminally and that that that
that extends way to uh to a whole bunch
of other issues like um hunter biden was
on the board of barisma is this uh uh
absolute malfeasance where it wasn't
just a quid pro quo it was him
protecting his son's business interests
but then of course you know his son and
he shared emails and a phone number and
joe biden told the american people that
he didn't know anything about his son's
business dealings and then we learned
that actually there's a bunch of photos
of him with his son's business partners
and they they actually do know each
other and that uh hunter biden was flown
on air force two to china to negotiate a
private equity deal oh boy the list goes
on all of these things that have not yet
been investigated that we need to know
about and then the best part
joe biden engages in a quid pro quo with
ukraine
his son on the board of barisma
and he says you got to fire the
prosecutor
and now as president
he is giving them billions of dollars
yeah doesn't that sound a little weird
to anybody so if i was standing there
and i was like we got a arrest a sitting
president and someone said what crimes
did he commit i'd be like oh boy
i mean let me line them up for you the
crimes i mean everyone's got to read the
laptop from hell because that will shock
you with the abundance of criminality
that's thoroughly documented there um of
course you know he's never been tried
and convicted everyone's innocent until
proven guilty but there's as you say
massive massive evidence of of
wrongdoing at a very huge scale
it's a huge national security problem
and this is what we really need to look
at uh hunter biden and by extension his
whole family the biden family kind of
acts as a criminal conglomerate uh in
terms of receiving funds collectively um
he received millions of dollars from a
high level
ccp related
alleged asset what wasn't it like five
million dollars in i don't remember the
exact amount but it was millions and
that doesn't happen without payback and
so now
sorry i believe it was a forgivable loan
right there you go i could be wrong i
could be like a donation right um but
look at our country again look backwards
reason backwards we our borders are open
um our children are being propagandized
our our cultural
norms and history is being degraded
are our you know
the the the the two groups as you were
saying ian are being set against each
other social media is deplatforming
critics of this dominant narrative that
is destroying the country um
you know images like worship is targeted
people are being arrested for holding
you know for convening their churches
and synagogues um so the ccp has a huge
role in all of this and this is how they
crush societies this is in their
playbook i think it's a vast
you know it is treason to accept money
from um to aid and abet our enemies and
i also read the description of what
impeachment is because that's what we do
at daily cloud and it takes a very low
bar for impeachment um high crimes and
misdemeanors is a pretty low bar so in
every way this is
you know that the debt that the bidens
have to china is devastating our country
um and it is much more serious uh than
than the kinds of things that people
have raised in the past
i think it's been
all the last sorry
the the president who you know even
though i didn't like him didn't vote for
him um had the fbi break into his house
i uh i'm glad you brought up the ccp i
think a lot about i don't like a
boogeyman i don't like creating a the
arch enemy that if we destroy them we
will we will win and everything will be
okay that's not how it works but they
are
basically provoking an extension of the
opium wars it's been going on for 120
years and now they're running fentanyl
through mexico right up into the country
totally giving it back to the to the
liberal economic order what we did to
them in the 1890s we annihilated their
their populace with with opium it's the
liberal international economy the lie
the liberal international economy we're
headed towards a new international
economy the night
yeah and it's going to be either i don't
know
i mean are you kidding us how it happens
are you familiar with thucydides trap no
it's a concept
that we talk about here ad nauseam
where uh whenever a dominant economic
power is about to be displaced by a
rising economic power
typically i should say i shouldn't say
whenever typically war breaks out oh
really so uh
i think i think it was like within the
past 500 years there have been 16
instances where something like this has
happened and 12 of them resulted in
major war wow so the argument is that
there are powerful interests in the
united states trying to prevent war
between the us and china by crippling
the united states and watching it
collapse before a war can break out so
the idea is if two powers reach a
similar level and they start competing
for who's going to dominate they
eventually just destabilize it
but if the dominant power is being
hacked away at the base and then it just
falls over
no war and told look at russia russia is
bad they're really bad let's pay more
attention to that the russia propaganda
was freakish in 2015 when it started
that's so that's such a good example of
how the people we know and i'm gonna say
me too got sucked into untruths i
believed that trump was a russian asset
because i read the new york times and i
watched cnn i believed it i believed
that he was in bed with the russians in
a way that was
traitorous to our country and now i know
that all of that was nonsense that the
dossier was nonsense but i didn't know
that when did you
start because so there are people who
have the opportunity to look into this
and choose not to because they're still
part of they still believe in the
narrative so strongly what changed for
you well honestly
i'm always trying to be open-minded and
i didn't think that i was self-selecting
out information that would have
cut against it but when you're reading
the new york times and watching cnn
there's such a repetition of
the washington times is a cult paper the
epic times is run by cult members the
you know they just dismiss every
conservative or independent or
libertarian outlet
and so i was lucky i married a
libertarian and
libertarianism saves lives
no but i got exposed to where the lies
were
and other sources of information and
then i met a lot of people producing the
epic times or producing these other news
news sources they're very credible
journalists i think i think libertarians
and conservatives right now are doing
and you guys people like you are doing
some of the only credible journalism
remaining in america um but i guess
that's just to say i thoroughly believed
the lie that trump was a russian asset
what was the moment that it changed
um that is a good question
i will i think that the legacy media had
to recently like a few months ago
step back i don't remember the evidence
that emerged but they stepped back and
said oh sorry that was a lie and the
dossier wasn't true either um whoopsie
yeah
but a lot of people were entrenched in
it for years and it's crazy that they
still won't let it go they still think
so
i think
i think it's actually quite simple
there's a bureaucratic state
civil servants who are appointed who are
not elected have an agenda they don't
care who the president is donald trump
is an arrogant blowhard so when he got
elected he just said excuse me no
and would not listen to what they they
insisted of him
and so they had to get him out of the
way
that's it i mean you look at his
administration so dramatically different
from the previous administrations right
in my lifetime i am 36 i've seen not
nearly as much as most people i think in
this well i shouldn't say most because i
don't know what the demographics are but
many people in this country who are
older than me i think majority of the
country older than me
maybe not i don't know but anyway my
point is
we get obama promising hope and change
and blows up kids
great then you get donald trump yeah he
does bad stuff
missile strike in syria drone strikes
but no new wars pulling our troops out
of the middle east pulling our troops
out of syria
trying to bring peace to the middle east
the abraham accords negotiating the deal
and i think it was uh was it kosovo
serbia or something like that then you
had um kim jong-un in north korea he
crossed into the dmz with no security in
a tremendous sign of peace and
leadership i mean it was shocking to me
that he did that they could have just
snatched him up taking the u.s president
got one they could have done a lot of
stuff they could have gripped his hand
and held it tight and said you're gonna
give us a million dollars aren't you or
or any nonsense like that they just
shook his hand and then he left it was
so dramatically different his foreign
policy that i'd seen in such a long time
that it was very clearly in the way of
the war machine and the establishment
politics of this country yeah well i
think you're
completely right and just each one of
those so embarrassing but each one of
those huge achievements which i really
didn't credit until pretty recently um
was dismissed and derided by the legacy
media i i have to
stress this every opportunity i get when
donald trump went to the dmz the
demilitarized zone in the koreas and he
met with kim jong-un
the media said he was ponying up to
dictators and it was bad and he was
causing problems
the president of the united states i
remember that with no security detail
entered an enemy nation the war with
north korea is still
there's still a war the war did not end
and donald trump
crossed into the dn crossed into north
korea
shook hands with kim jong-un smiled and
waved for photos and then walked back
and i was just watching this shocked
like
whoa dude yeah i mean this is this this
olfish
blowhard reality tv guy just risked his
life right in a sign of peace yeah and
the media just crapped all over him for
it and i was just like dude or or how
about this one
we lefties really hated the war in
afghanistan we really hated all those
wars that was the war machine
embarrassing to acknowledge president
trump actually brought our men and women
home you know he he scaled down the war
machine um no one gave him credit for
that on our side of it i guess what i
would say for the record though is as a
survivor of sexual assault the way he
spoke about women was catastrophic and i
could not bring myself to vote for
someone who is so dismissive about
sexual abuse it's that simple maybe that
was short-sighted of me but i kind of
shouldn't have to he should have had
advisors saying look just talk you know
apologize you know talk about it
compassionately say you've learned
whatever say you will try harder in the
future to not be you know horribly
abusive or describe women in horribly
abusive ways or describe sexual assault
this is when he said
this is when he was like when you're
famous they let you you know yeah but
even his apology apology afterwards was
very very dismissive and i think that
was a very painful moment for you know
the 33 of women who've been sexually
abused before they were 18 and the 17 of
men um and and it was so hard for me
personally to get over that this is what
i think a lot of the really die-hard
trump supporters need to pay attention
to i agree there's there's a lot of them
that you know they'll say like don't
care it's funny it's awesome i'm like i
i can appreciate you think it's funny
and it's no problem like i i hear trump
and i laugh i i do appreciate him being
strong and aggressive i'm just trying to
convey
when i got into a car
i was going to glenn beck's studio
and the driver was a mexican immigrant
who came to america and became a citizen
and he said yeah man i love trump i just
wish you would stop saying that stuff
and i'm like
trump
does get a lot of people by being
aggressive but he could make some moves
that would retain that while also being
more appealing to run-of-the-mill people
who don't like that abrasive language i
remember one of the criticisms he got
all the time is that he wasn't
presidential enough he wasn't dignified
enough and
while that is a little bit different
from what the comments you're pointing
out i do think
in some ways some trump supporters
doubled down they like that he has these
rough edges and they like that he
doesn't sound the way obama sounded and
he doesn't sound the way career
politician biden sounds or sounded um i
don't like hate man i can agree that
like his language around certain topics
could be better i
would not like to be the adviser to try
and corral trump into changing his
speech patterns
but i
i mean
i think
republic or conservative voters are
willing to
embrace flaws or at least uh
pick and choose flaws differently i
think
some of the hang up with a lot of
especially young liberals that i know is
that it has to be absolute like there
cannot be any sins and that's ultimately
completely unreasonable well who on the
like who among you has no sin right who
are they going to find from their side
of the aisle who has no sin to run for
office right i guess they don't have to
worry they have to be hidden enough
right we have to not let them surface
right i think the left um has a tendency
to just scream lie to me please
[Laughter]
but what i mean by that is
they would prefer hillary clinton who
sounds correct i mean well let's be real
they didn't want hillary clinton either
everybody kind of groaned but they would
prefer barack obama's charming big old
smile lying to your face and blowing up
kids if it made you feel good he says
plug your ears kids just plug your ears
everything's fine blow em up
whereas donald trump is the opposite i
loved it and then one of the greatest
moments in american presidential history
was when he's outside like in he's
outside the white house on the rose gun
or whatever and they asked him about
saudi arabia and he goes we're gonna
sell a bunch of weapons to saudi arabia
it's gonna be great for our economy and
then all the anti-war left was like he
just said it he said he just completely
admitted
what they've never admitted that we're
just selling weapons to make money to
bolster our economy and trump just said
it and i was laughing the intercept
called him the most honest and dishonest
president of our lifetime wow or or or
the united states or whatever and i was
just like
the funny thing is trump lies about
things that are dumb like his ego stuff
like no i didn't say that you can't say
that about me but then he just openly
admits all this crazy stuff like we're
going to keep the troops in syria for
the oil we like the oil folks right
there it was good it's like
right now but in retrospect i mean with
all of those flaws i mean it was it was
peace and prosperity did you vote for
him in 2020 no
i did yeah but you know the
administration i voted for
colluded to silence me with oh yeah yeah
so it didn't work out that well thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there